Russia has pushed the pause button on
the flow of Green from Ukraine to
countries facing growing hunger and high
food prices saying it would not restart
the Black Sea grain deal until its own
demands are met she is completely
unjustifying weaponizing the hunger of
the people the agreement was reached
last summer to allow food to leave the
region after Russia's Invasion began in
February 2022 it ensured ships would not
be attacked entering and leaving
Ukrainian ports among moscow's demands
are for Russia to get its food and
fertilizer to the world despite a
separate deal made to assist in the
movement of both products amidwestern
sanctions through the black seed deal
U.N Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez
says hundreds of thousands of tons of
food grain has been shipped by the world
food program and the soaring prices of
wheat vegetable oil and other food
products have gone down
but Matthias margulis at the University
of British Columbia says the pause
prompts questions concerns about sort of
the uh continued supply of grain and
other foodstuffs from Ukraine to
developing countries of particular which
are their main export markets he adds
while the suspension of the deal would
not have direct impacts on North America
or Canada for that matter it could still
create a ripple effect if markets react
poorly that could lead to a rise in food
prices across the board so it could
contribute to food inflation here in
North America and globally in the months
since the deal was brokered Moscow has
complained restrictions on shipping and
insurance have hampered its agricultural
exports but despite this Russia has
shipped record amounts of wheat Africa
the Middle East and Asia are the regions
most likely to be impacted by the
suspension with officials behind some
assistance programs expressing
disappointment I think it's unfortunate
that we use and we can use food
as a tactic Turkish president erdogan
says he believes Russian President
Vladimir Putin wants the deal to
continue and steps are being taken to
resume the agreement even as Global Food
security remains hanging in the balance
Sean Preble Global News